we have already learned about the Calvin
cycle the light independent phase of the
photosynthesis photosynthesis reaction
now if you haven't yet watched that
video I would strongly recommend you go
back and watch that video about Calvin
cycle which is super simplified and the
link is given in the description but
roughly Calvin cycle has three phase the
stage one which is carbon fixation when
the co2 is fixed with the help of
Rubisco enzyme and forms
3-phosphoglycerate desert and that's the
first stable compound in the c3 cycle
now the stage two is reduction of three
fees phosphoglycerate to musa aldehyde 3
phosphate and this chrisser aldehyde 3
phosphate molecule is used to regenerate
ruby rubp or it might be used to form
glucose now we completely understand
that Rubisco or ribulose bisphosphate
carboxylase is a key enzyme of the
calvin cycle in this video we are going
to talk about the mode of action of
Rubisco enzyme and how it can work in
different situation and depending upon
the differences in oxygen and carbon
dioxide concentration how goobies co can
function in two different regime so
first regime is the carboxylase where
Rubisco can interact with car Bock
carbon dioxide to form 3
phosphoglycerate and Rubisco enzyme is a
multi marek enzyme some of its domain
are encoded by the chloroplast plus
genome and some of its domain are
encoded by the nuclear genome and
Rubisco enzymes functionality is
dependent upon co2 concentration or -
concentration even magnesium ion and pH
so depending upon oxygen and carbon
dioxide concentration Rubisco has to
decide that whether it would perform the
reactions of the Calvin cycle
ultimately in a productive fashion
produce glucose or carbohydrates which
would help in the plant growth or
otherwise it would divert into a
wasteful process and form to phosphor
glycolate and that is the
photorespiration part so Rubisco exists
decision based on oxygen concentration
carbon dioxide concentration pH
temperature and magnesium ion
concentration all of these things are
determining factor which pathway Rubisco
would be involved in so let's look at
its carboxylic activity first so here is
the carbon dioxide and this carbon
dioxide is going to be fixed in the
regulars 1/5 bisphosphate so first there
are lysine residues in the enzyme which
actually deprotonates aruba lose 1/5
bisphosphate and ultimately forms an
Indian intermediate with this in dile
intermediate the carbon dioxide
interacts and the carboxyl group is
incorporated hence the name carboxylate
ultimately that gives rise to two
molecules of 3 phosphoglycerate this
regime is preferred when the carbon
dioxide concentration is high
alternatively Rubisco can work in our
oxygen aspera dime or oxygen s regime
where the first step is pretty similar
the deprotonation by the lysine group of
the enzyme rubisco forms a in dye all
intermediate now this entire
intermediate is a highly reactive
substance which can interact with oxygen
as well now once it is interacting with
oxygen it would form several
intermediates which would ultimately be
hydrolyzed to two phospho glycol 8 and 3
phosphoglycerate and this to phospho
glycol it would enter the first photo
respiration cycle and would not produce
the carbohydrates so this is quite a
wasteful process but what we learn in
this video is the carboxylation paradigm
the oxygenation regime of Rubisco and
its functionality so I hope you enjoyed
this short video if you liked this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe thank you
I'll keep watching